alors soyez là où la bienvenue un votre
émission du 24 mars sur facebook live ou
encore aujourd'hui c'est le 26 mars deux
jours plus tard sur les autres
plateformes rci et youtube
vous êtes donc le bienvenu à cette
émission le tam-tam canada autour de - 2
amis de la station d'abord paloma
martinez de la section latino américains
de radio canada international bonjour
parlement est également l'habitude et
ceux sur qui repose toute la technique
de cette émission spéciale
il s'agit de leonardo cheminots bonjour
là bonjour c'est la technique à
radio-canada ça prend trois techniciens
pour faire une chose quelqu'un pour le
son c'est un peu normal et quelqu'un
pour la vidéo et ça c'est vous et puis
on salue on dit bonjour à ceux qui nous
regardent en ce moment ici stéphane
parent alors de quoi va-t-on parler
aujourd'hui d'une affaire plutôt
controversé une affaire controversée ça
va devenir controversé
on y travaille depuis plusieurs jours
alors on a tout part d'une question
question tam-tam qu'on a affiché sur
facebook plus tôt cette semaine
vous voulez nous la lire parce que ça
m'a fait rire non un peu on en discutera
pas corps qu'est ce qui changerait si du
jour au lendemain les femmes seulement
mes soucis les sommes qui pourraient
donner naissance pour ses enfants mais
ça va faire
et peut-on non mais ça vous a fait venir
ça m'a fait rien parce que je me suis
toujours posé cette question
personnellement âge et que je regardais
a d'autre part
à travers le monde trouvait que le
travail des mères était simple et non
quand on se lève puis on se couche le
vous avez déjà sérieusement comme couple
discuté de cette affaire avec votre
enfant avec sa famille en a déjà discuté
ça effectivement
parce que bon monfils justement des fois
il trouvait que c'était exactement la
même chose est père ou mère et non ce
n'est pas là heureusement que les pères
et les mains en d'euros différents a
joué dans une famille donc je serais
rappelé à mon fils que garder un enfant
neuf mois d'assaut vendre ces quelques
mots
j'avais déjà tenté l'expérience non non
non non mais j'imagine mais vous avez
conviendra fin les eaux calmes trois
fois donc le quatrième est ce que vous
pourriez le mettre au monde
mon premier fils ya un problème
attention et la lactation
j'ai déjà un petit jeu côté pas d'avoir
les bébés comme tel mais j'ai déjà dit à
ma femme je pouvais travailler attendre
les six mois mais c'est le côté
paresseux qui le fait mon côté mais
pardonnez moi je n'ai pas réfléchi avant
de parler c'est très rare que je fais ça
écoutez mais sérieusement vous pensez
que ce n'est peut-être pas passé médical
manger des nouvelles pour vos vraies
infos voici la question
un tour de temps rapidement il y en a 2
donc ce sera rapide conçu sur est ce
qu'un homme a déjà était enceinte dans
le monde et donner naissance à un enfant
les eaux
oui oui oui oui
opposé à une deuxième question c'est
parce que vous avez vu les images que
j'ai laissés sur notre plan non non on a
vu alors pendant qu'on les regarde ces
images qui sont la démonstration la
preuve comme dirait donald trump c'est
évident alors on y voit un jeune homme
qui s'appelle attend dé voir que je
retrouve son véritable nom il s'agit du
premier homme enceintes au monde en 2007
tomasz bity sy là il était comme ça a
ainsi mis artificiellement puisque son
épouse avait des problèmes de pet
infertiles
il a donné non pas naissance d'abord il
ya eu une césarienne pour retirer les
enfants et les enfants y en avait trois
emile a donné naissance par la suite à
un autre trio street a dit replay en
miles qui se porte en bonne santé et ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas de la fausse
nouvelle
sauf qu'un tellement un peu faux dans
cette histoire
juste un peu ah d'accord alors c'est que
ce jeune homme est en fait une jeune
femme
à l'origine il avait donc conserver tout
ce qu'il fallait pour que les choses se
produisent de façon naturelle dangereux
on les appelle les x et xi sait qui on
est venus williams canal mondiale et du
10/11 ont préparé les deux organes
féminins et masculins
ok il dans un moment donné c'est eux
qu'ils doivent décider lesquelles parce
que les deux taureaux ça marche pas
alors dans un moment donné si la
personne se sent plus féminin que
masculin que choisir puis annulé un des
deux organes qui s'est passé à je ne
sais pas je n'ai pas d'autres détails si
vous voulez on va peut-être ajouter un
hyperlien sur la page de tintane canada
justement pour poursuivre avec d'accord
marché conclu avant de parler d'autre
chose sérieuse des réactions nos
auditeurs de nos lecteurs sur facebook
par rapport à cette question tout à fait
farfelu mais qu'un fond de science
derrière tout ça je vais vous proposer
d'aller fouiller dans les archives
toujours de radio canada international
c'est ce qu'on propose chaque semaine à
travers notre conversation de parler des
sages femmes au canada ne peut pas être
au courant mais ici au canada
contrairement à ce qui se passe dans
bien des pays en voie de développement
c'est d'abord à l'hôpital qu'on accouche
et non pas dans les mains d'une sage
femme
voici donc un extrait d'une de ces sages
femmes au québec interviewé par raymond
des marteaux récement alors que un
groupe de cinq femmes ont mis sur pied
des maisons d'accouchement
donc en dehors des liens de le des
hôpitaux est hors d'atteinte donc de la
médecine traditionnelle et donc redonner
aux femmes ici l'option comme c'était le
cas avant la seconde guerre mondiale au
québec au canada d'avoir recours aux
services d'une sage femme on regarde la
vidéo après sont encore un peu plus
notre affaire
quand une femme accouche
elle va aller donner la vie dans un
environnement contrôlé les règles à
suivre ne serait-ce que s'ils pourront
femmes d'accoucher dans la position de
son choix de normaliser l'acte de donner
la vie est ce que les femmes puissent se
les réapproprier et le vivre comme elles
le veulent il veut au niveau légal ya
pas vraiment de problème en soi sans que
l'on n'ait pas tenu d'aller à l'hôpital
on n'est pas tenu d'avoir un le
professionnel qui nous suit ou quoi que
ce soit une femme peut accoucher c'est
le voeu seul avec sa mère et son
conjoint que je veux dire simplement
plus que c'est surtout un carcan
culturelle qui fait que les femmes sont
maintenus dans un système qui fait
qu'elles doivent donner la vie dans un
espace extrêmement encadrée et
réglementée d'une comme un kidnapping de
la part de la concession misiones
exactement ya des historiennes mais qui
se sont penchés sur la question qu
effectivement une mainmise sur le fait
de donner la vie or la profession
médicale
ici au québec de façon très très clairs
et appuyé l'an ce sens qu ils sachent
femmes ont été un des rares pays
industrialisés où il sage femme n'était
plus dans le système de santé n'était
pas légal alors imaginez vous serez sans
doute justement depuis 1999 que on a le
retour des sages femmes dans notre
système de soins autrefois c'était
seulement les médecins glowacki on
pourra voir à faire depuis les années 50
on va dire pour nous laisse un peu de
moyens en fait que les femmes puissent
obtenir le soutien que la majorité des
femmes ont envie d'avoir
alors voilà la flexibilité dans des
choses de la vie importante pour nous
c'est de plus en plus quelques
sentiments qui est exprimé par les
canadiens ce mouvement des sages femmes
qui revendiquent donc une place au
moment de l'accouchement
on ressent partout au pays on a autre
chose à vous proposer
pendant longtemps il fallu convaincre
qu'on tentait de convaincre les médecins
que les sages femmes s'étaient aussi
sécuritaire que d'aller à l'hôpital
et maintenant il ya des statistiques et
des enquêtes qui le prouvent donc là on
ne parle pas que dans le désert on peut
avoir un véritable de notre conversation
avec son médecin en moins j'aimerais
aller vers les sages femmes est ce que
vous avez déjà eu
vous êtes allé à l'hôpital je parle trop
personnelle dans mes questions mais je
suis allé à l'hôpital pour mon premier
accouchement d'abord parce que c'est un
accouchement un peu difficile donc j'ai
pas voulu prendre des risques et j'ai
fait j'ai eu raison parce qu'évidemment
il a fallu que honda il ya une salle
d'opération pour l'accouchement dès mon
premier enfant donc c'était une sage
décision de ne pas léser tda première
sage-femme ou es ce que vous avez donc
une césarienne pouvant venir cette
question de la césarienne au canada voir
la popularité entre guillemets de cette
opération qui est extrêmement décisive
n'est ce pas là pour l'avenir si on
regarde par exemple ce qui se passe dans
les pays en voie de développement
c'est d'abord les sages femmes papotent
pas d'abord mais souvent les sages
femmes qui donnent naissance aux enfants
et on sait qu'il ya eu toute une
campagne depuis l'an 2000 un haut niveau
de l'onu pour essayer de plus en plus
d'offrir l'accouchement en milieu
hospitalier dans les pays en voie
développement ça fait partie des sommes
extraordinaires qui ont été dépensés en
vertu de ça et je ce rapport aussi qu'il
vient du sénégal tout à fait récent on
dit que les objectifs 4 et 5 du
millénaire de l'onu
ça ne fonctionne toujours pas malgré
certains progrès ont dit que là bas le
taux de mortalité c'est au niveau de la
naissance l'a 65 % seulement des femmes
qui vont à l'hôpital ont là-bas c'est un
défaut chez nous ce serait comme faire
et le taux de mortalité au niveau des
nouveaux nés là-bas et de 29 décès pour
mille
sens c'est quand même plus élevé
rencontre paraît en moyenne de plusieurs
autres nations 392 décès pour 100 mille
naissances au niveau de mortalité
maternelle ça aussi fournir compte au
niveau des dangers et le nombre de décès
maternels pour 100 mille naissances
vivantes atteint en moyenne 16 décès par
tranche de 100 mille personnes les
centres dans les pays développés jc
statistiques là pour voir maintenant ce
qui se passe au canada
vous êtes prêts alors voici un auditeur
en afrique au sénégal justement quel
hasard monsieur mba lots sympas qui nous
posent des questions et on y répond on
adore répondre à nos auditeurs et aussi
à ceux sur facebook et des questions à
ce moment et qu'il valait pendant que
ceux ci est diffusé en deux ans
une façon qui nous regardent mais en
fait il nous écoute je vous écoute
elvis et licha niang et cie il est en
train de nous imposer
et si je comprends bien on est prêt
maintenant pour monsieur mba louf
peuvent sympa et on l'écouté restants
un bon soir les cours de la bourse alité
maternelle de la mortalité maternelle au
canada si vous commettez un pays est
clairement sous développés que la
couverture sanitaire n'est pas demain
qu'on ne le fait que le cas de mortalité
aux états unis pour comparer un peu les
choses
aujourd'hui environ 15 femmes qui
meurent des suites de leur grossesse ou
de leur accouchement pour cent mille
naissances en france et pas loin 10
femmes sur son île au canada
généralement de quatre à onze
accouchement sur 100000 au canada se
termine par le décès de la femme canada
aurait à chapitre l'une des meilleures
performances au monde sinon la meilleure
au début des années 20 1920 donc à
presque 100 ans
c'était environ 500 décès pour 100 mille
naissances allons voilée que on a fait
beaucoup de progrès depuis sentent un
peu près ici au pays où québec notamment
on a des réponses qu'on va vous propose
maintenant notre question qui est très
d'actualité scientifique est ce que les
hommes pourraient de naissance à des
enfants
je vous dis ça vient de sortir au mois
de novembre c'est une chercheuse aux
états unis j'ai le nom ici l'adapteur
karine chang directrice du programme de
prévention de la fertilité d'université
de calories californie du sud
elle dit elle est très optimiste par
rapport à la capacité des hommes de
bientôt donner naissance aux enfants
l'anatomie masculine dit elle est
féminine ne sont pas si différentes
[Rires]
y'a pas de photos d'accord on a des
dopés réponse on va commencer par
monsieur ou madame sylvie des marais
qu'est ce qu'il réponde elle répond à
nos questions
elle dit alors qu'on parle d'une sorte
surpopulation at on vraiment besoin
d'une telle démarche
je sais pas c'est en tout cas la
question se pose
elle est posée elle est posée d'autre
part il ya dix ans nous commente ac lui
va tekassala dit ce serait une
abomination
je sens que c'est un homme ça françoise
d'opinion bien sûr
françoise de partout en france on la
connaît bien oui oui ça fait au moins
deux trois semaines qu'elle n'avait pas
écrit à notre émission et on est fiers
de la retrouver
et voici ce qu'elle dit et c'est une
longue réponse ou encore son mari y
passe
qu'est ce qu'elle dit elle dit je pense
que ce serait rocambolesque
mon mari a déjà un problème de surpoids
hilda et si on devait en plus lui
ajouter une deuxième grosse bosse et je
crains beaucoup pour les chances de
survie de ce pauvre d'ordre intérieur
aubin cela dit je pense que ce serait
une chose incroyable et heureuse si les
hommes pouvaient enfin vivre notre
réalité et nos soucis et si c'est la
bonne question ici un couple réussit un
couple là j'ai pu la bonne feuille et
valoir
et si un couple pouvait décider qui des
deux devrait amener l'enfant monde on
assiste et réalmont
enfin égal j'ai parlé de ça à mon mari
et il me dit de vous dire toutefois que
vous rêver en couleur et qu'il
n'accepterait jamais ce marché voilà
enfin un homme qui s'exprime qui n'a pas
peur de s'exprimer
je vais on va parler maintenant de la
cus moi je trouve depuis que j'ai ça en
tête
vu que je suis le petit garçon part des
césariennes parce que j'ai posé des
questions va comme tout le monde sur les
abeilles a même ordonné je me suis
réveillé je sortais de mon lit et on m'a
expliqué que des fois fallait procéder à
une grande courbe pour trois ans
explique ce type et leurs enfants et
ensuite dont on peut voir évidemment
quand on est curieux les images les
blessures que c'est en laisse et on se
dit bao finalement à l'enfant
il est vivant donc c'est essentiel sauf
que au canada il ya des médecins qui
trouve qu'il ya un recours trop
systématique à la césarienne parce qu'on
se dit oui oui en argentine c'est la
même chose faisait de plus en plus
enfin la première chose qu'on propose
c'est enfin là c'est salir midi en date
parce que comme ça on fait rage et que
ces choses c'est qu'on sait contrôler et
là une date précise
une après six personnels c'est programmé
mon problème c'est avec les astres mais
quoi oui parce que je suis né le 7
février puis je suis berceau puis je
voulais pas être long mais si il ya je
suis né à ce qu'est mon médecin m'a dit
lassé la date précise il annonce trois
jours plus tard comment est-ce que ils
vont réagir les cinq autres vite mais on
avait le choix entre l'autre version
denner d'autres on préfère ce sujet
d'accord d'accord on dans notre machine
à remonter le temps à voir dans le temps
on a en a cette capacité on en reparlera
un moment donné je fais longtemps je
propose
j'annonce une émission sur le futur mais
elle tarde alors au sujet des
césariennes précision très sérieux sur
100 enfants nés au canada
combien le sont ils sont nés à la suite
d'une césarienne sur 100 enfants
celui qui se rapproche plus de la
réponse ne recevra ne sommes pas
soit 130 30 40 40
et bien c'est plus de 45 quelque chose
seriez pas là c'est moi qui est je vais
c'est vrai là il fait allusion un radis
bay notre webmestre du côté francophone
de radio canada qui est absente
aujourd'hui pour des raisons de santé
et je voulais vous demander on voit bien
alors on écoute cet extrait de reportage
qu'on a préparé pour vous il s'agit d'un
extrait dont je vous préviens le reste
ce qui est bon c'est sûr là c'est sur le
site web de tam-tam canada nous on
montre comment fouillé vous ensuite vous
allez fouiller
voici un extrait d'un reportage préparer
récemment sur le phénomène des six
organes au pays
en réponse je pense un auditeur je me
souviens plus de quel pays on va
regarder et voir si on peut deviner de
qui il s'agit en fait parce qu'il ya un
besoin et un réel besoin qui eux qui
n'est connu depuis un an ghislaine
renault fondatrice d'une fondation qui
existe depuis quelques années au québec
j'allume une étoile à une entente avec
le centre hospitalier universitaire de
la ville de québec est presque 100 % des
parents acceptent l'offre de son service
parce que tu es tu arrives à la maison
que l'hébreu vide tu as des rêves que tu
réalises repas puis tout ton entourage
autour de toi ben ils peuvent pas
connaître enfin ils ont juste entendu
parler puis la photo ba est le parrain
est de l'entourage avec les frères et
soeurs à venir à voir que cet enfant
d'exister parce que c'est ce que pour
les parents c'est fait avec c'est un
deuil avis partir de 18 semaines jusqu'à
39 semaines aux sept ans plus tard quand
on a un appel on se déplace on fait les
photos quand on commençait première fois
c'est quand même c'est très émouvant
c'est ici c'est même ce 13e avec le
teint tu te dis garde j'ai un travail à
faire il faut que je fasse je travaille
pour les parrains elle offre un service
de photographies fait par des bénévoles
qui ont reçu une formation pour
effectuer leur travail
l'icca il s'agit de prendre des photos
avant et après donc c'est ce que je vois
pas loin dans la pensée je sais que pour
les parents c'est extrêmement difficile
sauf que moi quand je quand j'entre dans
la pièce je vais avec douceur avec
respect en dix ans par un conte est là
pour eux qu'on va faire les photos qui
ont besoin le teint qui ont besoin qu'on
soit là alors on essaie de faire quand
même rapidement parce que les parents
sont un peu un état de choc sont dans
leur bulle
alors on en fait le plus possible puis
après ce bon peut on peut se retirer de
la chambre on remet quand même une photo
par un anneau de départ de l'hôpital
la fondation j'allume une étoile a fait
aussi un service de retouche de photos
et de vidéos
nous les photos quand les rats non par
un sont retouchées parce que des fois le
petit b la peau est abîmée où et quand
il est petit bébé de 18 à 24 22 semaines
sont sont plus rouge et tous ceux
d'entre pour l'appareil ok sont capables
de regarder par sylvie qui ont vu mais
pour le montrer où la toile la famille
des fois c'est difficile et des gens qui
ont des difficultés à les voir donc
encore mais les photos aux parents les
photos sont tous très touchés sont en
noir et blanc mais avec eux comme ça il
ya une photo qui peuvent y en a beaucoup
qui vont les mettre dans un petit quart
dans la maison et comprend les présente
à la famille et l'entourage le fait que
c'est plus facile à regarder
alors voilà ça c'est un extrait de notre
reportage qu'on a préparé pour vous sur
ça ne parlait pas de ces organismes
puis tout ça se trouve sur la page web
de tomtom canada
non c'est parce qu'on a faut pas
souligner les erreurs quand on les fait
alors on les oublie pas mais c'était sur
le sujet de l'émission qui porte sur les
naissances les dangers tout ça et donc
si vous voulez vous pouvez avoir plus
d'informations sur le phénomène des six
ariane au canada rien n'a été enlevée
sinon à cette émission alors on va
parler maintenant d'une enquête auquel
s'est livrée radio-canada et cybit si
c'était l'automne dernier vers la fin de
l'automne
et vous en avait même fait
un écrit journal et c'est que vous avez
produit un article là dessus vous même
en recopiant les informations c'est au
sujet des problèmes qui lie à l'hôpital
des surprises pour les coupes qui vont
donner naissance d'apprendre qu'il ya
des problèmes sérieux dans les hôpitaux
d'abus il y a deux serrures et des abus
dans les unités des naissances du canada
c'est une enquête de l'équipe
d'investigation du réseau anglais de
radio canada subissent investigate ya
dévoilé
justement à l'automne dernier les
résultats d'une recherche journalistique
concernant des plaintes d'abus présumés
dans les unités des maternités des
plusieurs sont plutôt canadienne quand
on parle de plainte mais on parle de
quoi
une femme qui s'est plaint d avoir est
d'avoir été abusés par les infirmiers
aller les verbalement ou même parfois
physiquement par des infirmières des
médecins dans les unités de naissance du
pays parce qu'il serait là le personnel
hospitalier pas assez nombreux il est
fatigué ou quoi celle là c'est encore à
déterminer justement mais probablement
que c'est le cas mais en tout cas un
alberta et en colombie britannique
on donne ces deux exemples en
particulier parce que ils sont elles
sont reçues ces territoires du pays les
plus de plaintes à travers le pays sont
7 163 plaintes qui se sont faites dans
une période de temps précis donc un
puits ailleurs au québec et en ontario
aussi il y a eu des plaintes est
importante donc lieu l'hôpital sainte
justine et l'hôpital sainte-justine de
montréal se dit que des cinq permis à
infirmières de l'hôpital on sonne l
alarme à 400 incidents dans les salles
d'accouchement plus important hôpital
pour enfants de la province
radio-canada a obtenu parce que ce fait
toucher 1 conjointement avec un du
canada et celui-ci a obtenu des rapports
qui font état du nombre d'incidents et
d'accidents ayant doublé et même triplé
dans les derniers mois comparativement à
la même période de l'année dernière et
les familles se plaignent de multiplier
les serrures de ne pas exercer dans des
communes
c'est leur travail dans des conditions
sécuritaires par manque de ressources
par manque de temps par manque de
sommeil aussi parce que des fois les
horaires qui ne sont attribuées sont pas
adéquats pour quelqu'un bouquet et pied
pas que ça à faire mais à qui parle
uniquement à leur nom un galet syndicats
ou six qui ont dit qu'un problème de
pénurie de personnel on a trop coupé
donc il se pourrait que toutes les
plaintes qui ont eu lieu ailleurs dans
le pays soient aussi régler un problème
est lié au personnel alors si vous etes
peut lire davantage sur une page de
tam-tam canada vous aviez des réflexions
par rapport à ça vous étiez au courant
non non j'en ai aucune idée mais je sais
par exemple que dans d'autres métiers où
les pilotes d'avion par exemple il faut
les changer chaque mille feux ils
peuvent pas travailler plus que ce
teaser c'est en huit heures je sais pas
combien de temps
c'est imprécis et justement pour faire
attention les gens qu'ils ont en charge
vie dans les cas des infirmières des
médecins
c'est la même chose de la même chose
c'est-à-dire d'émettre des alertes et
cohérent à partir de la capacité du
commun des dettes là je devais être là
pas seulement physiquement parce que
quand on travaille devant un ordinateur
ou un bureau bien on n'a pas tout à fait
la même responsabilité
oui on peut déduire les gens les
contrôleurs des gens mais on n'a pas la
vie des gens donc si on veut en savoir
davantage sur la page de tam-tam canada
y est plus de données que ce qu'on vous
a fourni un autre débat on devait parler
de l'émission controversé aujourd'hui
donc je ne sais pas si les gens sentent
que ont nettement
on fait tout ce qu'on peut pour faire
soulever cette émission comme comme un
soufflé maintenant la question de
l'allaitement allaiter en public ait eu
des débats au canada cette madame on l'a
vu allaiter en public grosse chicane
pourquoi ce qu'elle fait ça madame
veuillez sortir de l'établissement on a
eu 1 ce genre sur voit bien depuis le
début des années de lui mais moi j'ai eu
plusieurs cas là il y apparaît qui est
un groupe de femmes qui sentent comme
auprès c'est parce qu'on les oblige à
l'été au sein parce que là maintenant
c'est devenu une affaire parce que si
vous le faites pas vous mettez en danger
la vie vos enfants on veut donc
autrefois c'était il y faut absolument
donner à l'enfant
cette formule de l'air difficile faite
par les gros fabricants on poussait ça
aujourd'hui c'est le contraire on a bien
dans le marché pensez vous qu'il ya des
pressions sur les femmes pour qu'elles
allaitent naturellement je crois que une
certaine pression peut se sentir pour
pour avoir été à l'hôpital moi même et
avoir accouché à l'hôpital je sais que
les discussions moi j'étais convaincu de
vouloir allaiter mes enfants mais je me
souviens que je sentais qu'elle est que
les infirmières insister beaucoup qui
est le passé beaucoup de temps avec moi
à bien faire ça pour la première fois la
deuxième fois la troisième fois donc je
sentais quai et c'était vraiment il
voulait que ça marche et voulait que ça
mange parce que et s'était convaincu
puis elles sont probablement raison au
niveau de la santé de l'enfant que c'est
la meilleure chose pour ses sentiers ces
anticorps pour la développement des
syndicats cependant il y à des femmes
et ça je vais le défendre aussi les
droits des femmes de décider s'il le
faut ou non parce que il y a aussi
d'autres manières de 2 pour l'enfant
d'obtenir tout ce dont il a besoin pour
sa santé non seulement à travers les
maternelles mais d'autres façons donc je
pense que c'est une question personnelle
et je ne demanderai pas aller aussi le
serai prêt à l'été ou non son enfant le
mans
naturel non mais je vais demander à
l'été c'est sa femme était et est décédé
et puis le bébé année c'était du monde
ailleurs le baby arrêtait pas de pleurer
elle était mort justement à un donna
naissance à ces enfants là et puis après
beaucoup de succession de la part de
bébé les je vous propose est choquée je
peux vous proposer d'écouter un extrait
de reportage qu'on a préparé sur le fait
même des femmes qui ne veulent pas
allaiter elles sont dans leur droit et
même des statistiques tendent à prouver
que ce n'est pas clair que l'allaitement
naturel est la seule façon d'offrir la
santé à long terme à ses enfants
et voici ce qu'on vous a préparé pour
vous seulement un extrait
c'était vraiment quelque chose que
j'avais un inconfort avec seulement la
simple idée face aux hawks en bonne mère
de deux enfants à gatineau ville voisine
de la capitale canadienne a tenté
l'expérience de l'allaitement naturel
par curiosité
une expérience qu'elle qualifie
aujourd'hui d'horribles avec tout ce
qu'on attend que les gens qui nous
encourage à essayer j'ai décidé
d'essayer
parce que c'était le meilleur pour ma
fille j'ai tiré mon lait
exclusivement pour ma fille pendant neuf
mois de temps puis la conseillère en
allaitement m'avait dit que seulement
tirer la liste n'est pas une option
le simple fait formé pour notre enfant
au sein par contre l'impasse a si mal vu
c'est à partir du moment où est-ce que
yo la bouteille de vin certaines
infirmières considère plus que c'est de
la lettre et c'est très très très sucré
qui mme courchesne est une autre mère
d'enfants de gatineau elle dit qu'elle
n'a pas hésité elle a opté pour le
biberon dès la naissance de son premier
enfant trop calmes et brandit d'année
avec un son stéréo ou même soupe qui est
quelqu'un qui allait petits concerts
qu'elle sait plus beau geste lui donner
la même chose qui donne la mort
moi j'ai pas pensé à sa lettre mais
sentant pas j'ai pas envie que c'était
peut être pour ou contre parce que je
suis totalement po ur si tu m'as demandé
et les bienfaits ont été prouvées de
suite c'est pas là la question
j'avais pas envie si tout cas on a vibré
au fond de ce qui nourrit ton enfant par
préhension t'es pas un moins un mois de
mars il aime pas moins t'es pas je te
crois est coupable tu fais pas nouveau
ça existait biberons et leurs traits
lisses si la date ne convient pas yapo
je vois pas le problème est et je pense
que j'espère qu'on vous a bien alimenté
quand vous êtes jeune et maintenant des
formations ont fait le reste nous on a
pris la relève
alors j'espère que ça s'est bien passé
pour vous du côté de la d'autres côté de
la caméra pour nous ça va bien très très
bien on a ajouté de l'éclairage ici en
studio on a maintenant des magnifiques
affiches présentant note nos véritables
couleurs radio canada international
nous avons même une caméra
supplémentaire et fonctionnel
elle fonctionne très très bien je
déteste ça mais c'est pas grave
ou bien faut faire ce sacrifice de soi
même quand même dans la vie n'est ce pas
merci beaucoup paloma
je sais que ça vous ferait plaisir donc
vous revenue la semaine prochaine en
esta on espère les eaux gimeno merci
beaucoup merci à toi merci est ici
stéphane parent à semaine prochaine